‏s ‏cbi
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان لا
اله
الا
الله اشهد
ان
محمد رسول الله
اشهد ان
محمدا
رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الصلاح حي على
فلاح
حي على
الفلاح الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
[Silence]
الله ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا
وسيئات
من يهده الله فلا مض له ومن يضلل فلا هادي
له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك
له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله صل الله
عليه وعلى اله وصحبته
اجمين الله
[Silence]
‏and
froms gu
can any
الله
عليه we
are us over
which
life med
we bey
‏tak الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان في خلق السماوات والارض واختلاف
الليل والنهار لايات لاولي الالباب
‏think
think the the fast of space have you
over looked and s of
wonder for
usn
greatness
leter life
iming the mountains
‏the flowers and
[Silence]
‏take
ever
think الله سبحانه وتالى وفي
للموقنين وفي انفسكم افلا
تبصرون الله سبحان وتالى
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وت اولم يروا الى الطير
مسخرات في جو السماء ما يمسكهن الا الله
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم يؤمنون
[Silence]
‏in the sky can us of allah over these
ref us recn greatness anding us cler to
him dear brothers and sisters as we go
as we go about our daily
lives let make ait to
and wonders
[Silence]
‏have you ever been by the fast escape
the towering
mountains the
end usate
عل صلى الله عليه
ولمر
وون في خلق السمات
والارض ويل لمن قراها ل يتر
فيها and do
notation is a concept that 18 times
[Silence]
‏life
الله الله وتلك الامثال نضربها للناس
لعلهم يتفكرون
[Silence]
الله حتى اذا اخذت الارض زخرفها وزينت وظن
اهلها انهم قادرون عليها اتاها
ليلا او نهارا فجعلناها حصيدا كان لم تغنى
بالامس كذلك نفصل الايات لقوم يتفكرون
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى وانزلنا اليك الذكر
لتب لناس ما نل اليهم ولعلهم يتفكرون
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى قل انما اع بواحده ان تقوموا لله
مثنى
ثم
تتفكروا
and this encourages us to think deep
about our andit
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول يسالونك عن الخمر
والميسر قل فيهما اثم قل فيهما اثم كبير
ومنافع للناس واثمهما اكبر من نفعهما
ويسالونك ماذا ينفقون قل العفو ذك يبين
الله لكم الايات لعلكم
[Silence]
تتفكرون الله
‏dear brothers and
sisters let let's make let make let make
to contemp allah cre and sence let us
take time each day to reflect on the
wonders around us and us cler to
our we ask to open our hearts and minds
to to increase us knowledge
anding and to strengthen our fai
اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله على احسانه والشكر له على
توفيقه وامتنانه واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله وعلى وصلى الله عليه وعلى اله
وصحابته وسلم تسليما كثيرا يقول الله
تعالى في كتابه العزيز ان في خلق السماوات
والارض واختلاف الليل والنهار لايات لاولي
الالباب هذه الايه الكريمه تدعونا للتفكر
في عظمه خلق السماوات والارض والتامل في
نظام الكون المتكامل الذي يعكس قدره الله
وحكمته والمصطفى عليه الصلاه والسلام ذات
مره قرا قوله تعالى
ويتفكرون في خلق السماوات والارض ثم قال
ويل لمن قراها ولم يتفكر فيها
والتفكر هو مفرده قرانيه تكررت في 18
موضعا في كتاب الله العزيز ويمكن تصنيف
هذه الايات على خمس مواضع اولها التفكر في
الخلق في الكون في الانسان والحيوان
والنبات وسوره النحل على سبيل المثال
وسوره النحل على سبيل المثال مليئه بتلك
الامثله وهي التي تسمى صوره النعم ان
ملاحظه الاعجاز في عمليه الخلق من العدم
وبث الحياه في الجماد الموات لينتفض
ويتحرك ويحس لهو من اعظم دلالات
الربوبيه
ثانيا التفكر في الامثال قال الله تعالى
وتلك الامثال نضربها
للناس لعلهم
يتفكرون وقد شبه الله الحياه الدنيا
بالمطر واختلاق نبات الارض به كما قال
تعالى حتى اذا حتى اذا خذت الارض زخرفها
والزيت
وظن اهلها انهم قادرون عليها اتاها امرنا
ليلا او نهارا فجعلناها حصيدا كان لم تغنى
بالامس كذلك نفصل الايات لقوم
يتفكرون ومن ذلك القصص فهي في مساق
الامثال والعبر والدروس الحياتيه التي
تقاس نتائجها ومحصرات ومحلاتها
وعواقبها
ثالثا التفكر في الوحي وخاصه القران وهو
التدبر والوقوف عند المعنى وعرض النفس
عليه
ومطالبتها بالترقي كما في قوله تعالى انا
انزلنا اليك الذكر لتبين للناس ما نزل
اليهم
ولعلهم
يتفكرون التف ر في الوحي يرسخ الايمان
ويجعل القارئ يسمع كلام الله وخطابه
وحديثه الى رسله وانبيائه وسائر عباده في
الدنيا وفي الاخره باسلوب معجز وبيان مبهر
وروحانيه
اسره والوحي نفسه دعوه الى التفكر واعمال
العقل والوجدان في التفاعل مع السياق وفي
كشف مجاهل الكون وافاقه
واسراره انه دين يحرض على التفكير ولا
يخاف من
العقل
رابعا التفكر في المواقف التي يتخذها
الانسان والالفاظ التي يطلقها دون رويه او
تحكم وتمثل تقليدا او ارثا غير محص او
يفعلها المرء بتشجيع وتصفيق ممن حوله
ينسيه ذاته ولذلك قال الله سبحانه
وتعالى قل انما اعظكم بواحده ان تقوموا
لله مثنى وفراده ثم
تتفكروا الموعظه في نظر البعض تختر والهاء
بينما هي هنا دعوه الى التعقل والتفهم
والاستيعاب والنظر المتعقل في
الجديد خامسا
التفكر في المصالح والمفاسد
وترجيح بعضها على بعض وهو لون من النظر
والتعقل يدرك منه المرء بقدر سعه عقله
وامتداد
تجربته وتعا من الضغوط السياسيه
والاجتماعيه ومن دقق فقه المصالح في معرفه
خير الخيرين وشري الشرين هذا ظاهر في قوله
سبحانه وتعالى يسالونك عن الخمر والميسر
قل فيهما اثم كبير ومنافع للناس واثمهما
اكبر من
نفعهما ويسالونك ماذا ينفقون قل العفو
كذلك يبين الله لكم الايات لعلكم
تتفكرون التفكر الرشيد يورث يورث حكمه
ويصنع وعيا ويقض يحكيها ابو سليمان
الداراني فيقول اني لاخرج من منزلي فما
يقع بصري على شيء الا رايت علي فيه نعمه
ولي فيه
عبره تامل سطور الكائنات فانها من الملا
الاعلى اليك رسائل وقد خط فيها لو تاملت
سطرها
الا كل شيء ما خلى الله
باطله نسال الله ان يفتح قلوبنا لتدبر
اياته وان يزيدنا ايمانا ويقينا وان
يرزقنا حب التامل في خلقه اللهم اجعلنا من
الذين يستمعون القول فيتبعون احسنه واغفر
لنا وارحمنا يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم انا
نسالك من الخير كله عاجله واجله ما علمنا
منه وما لم نعلم ونعوذ بك اللهم من الشر
كله عاجله واجره ما علمنا منه وما لم نعلم
اللهم انصر اخواننا المستضعفين في كل مكان
وخص منهم اخواننا في فلسطين وخص منهم
اخواننا في فلسطين اللهم كن لهم حافظا
ومعينا ومؤيدا ونصيرا اللهم احفظهم من بين
ايديهم ومن خلفهم ومن فوقهم نعوذ بعظمتك
ان يوتانوا من تحتهم اللهم اشف مرضاهم
وداوي جرحاهم واطعم جائعهم وانصرهم بنصر
من عندك وحدك لا شريك لك يا ذا الجلال
والاكرام ربنا لا تزغ قلوبنا بعد اذ
هديتنا وهب لنا من لدنك رحمه انك انت
الوهاب اللهم صل وسلم على عبدك ورسولك
محمد البشير النذير والسراج المنير وارضى
الله اللهم عن الصحابه والتابعين ومن
تبعهم باحسان الى يوم الدين وعنا معهم
بكرمك واحسانك يا ارحم الراحمين ان الله
يامر بالعدل والاحسان وتاء بال القربى
وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعظكم
لعلكم تذكرون واذكروا الله العظيم الجليل
يذكركم واشكروه على نعمه يزيدكم ولا ذكر
الله اكبر والله يعلم ما تسمعون واقيم
الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا ال الا
الله اشهد ان محم رسول
الله الصلاه ح على
الفلاح قد قا الصلاه قدت الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استو استقيم
اتد
cl
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى
والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى ثم لا يموت
فيها ولا يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم
ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا ل في الصحف
الاولى صح
ابه
ومو الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين هل اساك حديث الغاشيه وجوه يومئذ
خاشعه عامله ناصبه تصلى نارا حاميه تسقى
من عين انيه ليس لهم طعام الا من
ضريع لا يسمي ولا يغني من جوع
وجوع يومئذ ناعمه لسعيها راضيه في جنه
عاليه لا تسمع فيها لاغيه فيها عين
جاريه فيها سرر مرفوعه
واكواب موضوعه ونمارق
مصفوفه وزرابي
مبثوثه افلا
ينظرون الى الابل كيف خلقت والى
السماء كيف رفعت والى الجبال كيف نصبت
والى الارض كيف سطحت فذكر
انما انت
مذكر لست عليهم بمسيطر
الا من تولى وكفر
فيعذبه الله العذاب الاكبر
ان الينا
ايابهم ثم ان عليه
حسابهم الله اكبر الله
اكر سميع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر اللهم صل على
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله
السلام السلام الله
[Silence]
‏come ‏in for mcct scho transition into
pr be and be bre sch two after reg sch
back make
annable sister and
se any toar
[Silence]
‏some
شاء
تالى جزك الله خير السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[Silence]
واياكم حياكم الله واياكم ان شاء الله
بارك الله فيك
مرحبا وياكم ان شاء الله حسنات امين ان
شاء الله جزاكم الله خير ان شاءك
[Silence]
‏n
ا ‏a
[Silence]
ا
‏b ‏k
[Silence]
ا